we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here is a caller
dipping us further into the black hole
of spanish pronunciations
that i sometimes do on the show
david sir
this is a reply to your discussion
of the pronunciation of spanish language
words please in my experience it's a
no-win situation
i have a friend felipe cervantes right
who is originally from chile
yet he often argues um with my friend
ernesto delgado okay who is from mexico
right about who is the best chess player
in history
felipe believes it is jose capablanca
right but ernesto disagrees so what are
you going to do right
in the end though they were able to
settle their differences over some um
and enchilada
so all's well that ends well i suppose
all right take care my friend bye yeah
no i understand that you know it's it's
one of these things where if you say
cappa blanca
dude don't you speak spanish why why are
you saying cappa blanca
and then if you say capablanca then
people say well dude that's really
jarring why if you're speaking english
you don't need to do that it is an
absolute no win it is the black hole of
spanish pronunciation thank you very
much for pointing it out we have a great
bonus show for you today but sadly the
stories are not exactly
fun stories
a woman was shot dead in manhattan
while pushing a baby stroller horrifying
story which we will talk about
four individuals have already been found
and charged in that mass casualty
tractor trailer death from texas that i
spoke to you about yesterday
and we are going to compare the sentence
handed down the prison sentence hand it
down to gilain maxwell
compared to the sentence handed down to
r kelly many writing in and saying david
it seems as though r kelly got a
disproportionately heavy sentence
compared to maxwell based on what they
were charged with what's going on here
we're going to talk about it and more on
today's bonus show
sign up at joinpackman.com
i will see you on the bonus show or
otherwise on tomorrow's program